this video was written by an ai
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
hello everyone my name is matt you may
have seen me on the live show as i do
with jay aka scitrek and i will be
making some videos on this channel
moving forward if you're in the facebook
group you will have already have seen
that i used an ai tool today and that ai
tool came up with some facts about
stargate which
are not only ludicrous and ridiculous
and completely not true but are also
quite funny so we're gonna read them out
today
fact one the cast geeks out over meeting
the show's writers the cast geeks out
over meeting the show's writers
the actors on stargate sg-1 were lucky
enough to meet the show's writers
producers and even the creator of the
franchise roland emmerich the cast
members were so excited to meet their
colleagues that they recorded interviews
while they were together the result was
interviews with the actors and writers
that were like nerdy fan conventions the
cast members were so passionate about
their show and the story lines they were
literally geeking out the interviews
were so much fun to watch and really
showed how much everyone loved the show
and really got into their characters i
just like the idea of uh the
throughout the entire ten seasons of
stargate happening they had not met the
writers who were writing the stories um
and they
they geeked out afterwards after meeting
them um
i i just find that funny fact two amanda
tappings epic slap amanda tapping played
samantha carter one of the strongest
female characters in the sci-fi genre
she was an astrophysicist who also
it was also a pilot and a soldier
tapping was a great fit for the role
because she brought a warmth to the
character and was a great
foil for the rest of the sg-1 team i'm
not sure why it says foil there typing's
character grew frustrated with a male
scientist and decided to give him a slap
across the face
i wonder which male scientist that would
have been i mean this didn't happen but
imagi i can imagine it being rodney
mckay
it has to be right the slap was so epic
that tapping and the rest of the cast
couldn't stop talking about it tapping
like the slap so much that she used it
again in other episodes the showrunners
eventually had to ask tapping to tone it
down a bit they didn't want her
character to become a slap happy bully i
just love the idea that um samantha
carter slapped someone so much i slapped
someone so hard
that amanda tapping the actress was like
i love this this is amazing i'm gonna
carry on doing it like it just
it wouldn't happen it doesn't it's
obviously not true but this is this is
gold fact three don't mess with amanda
tapping ever tapping is no nonsense
she's someone who knows what she wants
and she won't let anyone stand in her
way this was evident in an episode when
she was working with a guest star who
was very different from the rest of the
cast
the actor was very serious and intense
tapping had to make sure the scene
played out in the right way but this got
guest star didn't take direction well
he thought he knew everything there was
to know about his character but didn't
but he didn't
tapping had to be firm with him
but she was also respectful she wasn't
rude or sarcastic like some other cast
members would have been
unfortunately the actor didn't get the
message and continued to interrupt
tapping
finally she had enough and screamed at
him to stop everyone was taken aback
no one ever spoke to the guest star like
that tapping handled the situation
perfectly and she made it clear that no
one should ever mess with her
can you just imagine a guest style comes
on to stargate sg1
doing a scene with amanda's having
he's talking over her and she just
screams at him like
if that actually happened we'd have all
heard about it by now
obviously that didn't happen
fact number four christopher judge drops
a mic judge brought tilt to life on the
show turk was a jafar who had been held
prisoner
held as a prisoner by the stargate
program he was an excellent warrior and
a good friend to the humans
judge brought a great amount of emotion
to the character and brought to life as
a complex and interesting person in one
episode judge character was about to
deliver a powerful monologue but he
dropped the mic
that might seem like an odd thing for a
professional actor to do but it was
actually pretty clever judge realized
that the script was too complicated for
the show's audience to understand
instead of trying to deliver confusing
dialogue and hoping the audience would
get it judge dropped the mic walked off
the set and refused to say the lines
that got the attention of the
showrunners and producers who rewrote
the script okay first of all
that entire fact obviously didn't happen
uh but it says tilk was a jafar who has
been held prisoner by the stargate
program doesn't mention the fact that he
defected from up office and joined the
stargate program as you know a member of
the team no no stargate command held
imprisoner against his will
[Laughter]
also why was he why would he have a
microphone that he can drop like i get
they might have microphones on their uh
on their clothes
for some scenes but if he's gonna
deliver a powerful monologue why would
he be there with a microphone like can
you just imagine an episode of stargate
where they're all sitting there with
microphones like colonel o'neill there's
a defractions of jafar coming
indeed indeed
okay and this is the final fact
the time everyone freaked out over
richard dean anderson's hair richard
dean anderson played jack o'neill the
lead character on stargate sg1 he was a
smart ass and lousy team leader who
always got himself and his team into
trouble anderson had natural hair and a
natural beard and so he didn't get a
chance to be someone else very often
however he had a chance to shave his
head for one episode and let his hair
grow for another
the casting crew was shocked when
anderson showed up with a bald head and
long hair
they immediately freaked out and started
taking pictures uh of each other with
anderson they then posted the pictures
online no one expected anderson to shave
his head or grow his hair out so it was
a total surprise plus the change
affected his character on the show and
made jack look much younger i'm just
imagining richard dean anderson now with
long hair and a beard um
also he says that he was a smart ass and
lousy team leader like he was obviously
the best team leader in like in all
stargate shows like he's
way better than john sheppard
way better than like
nicholas rush or
uh
colonel young and he never had a beard
and he was never bald in an episode at
all
[Laughter]
i get this was written by an ai but come
on they're supposed to be smart but
there you go all of those facts were
generated by artificial intelligence and
as you can tell they're not very good
they're obviously not true but they are
pretty funny if you are new to the
youtube channel please hit like and
subscribe and press the bell
notification so you don't miss any
videos also consider becoming a fully
fledged side trekker hit the join button
down below my name's matt you've been
watching sidetrack and i'll see you in
another video
[Music]